en france est aujourd'hui que s'ouvre le
procès des trois policiers soupçonnés d'
usage abusif de la force envers des
gilet jaune et ce au lendemain du
troisième anniversaire de la naissance
du mouvement l'un est jugé pour avoir
asséné un coup de matraque dans le dos
d'une manifestante les deux autres pour
des tirs de nbdl et précision notre
reporter nadège abderrazak devant le
tribunal judiciaire de paris
plusieurs audiences ce jeudi au tribunal
judiciaire de paris la première celle de
deux policiers qui vont être jugés pour
les tirs de l bd qui ont blessé en gilet
jaune lors d'une manifestation en
février 2019 à paris la seconde concerne
la sphère d'un policier accusé d'avoir
asséné un coup de matraque dans le dos
d'une manifestante les faits se sont
déroulés à paris lors de la
manifestation de gilet jaune du 20 avril
2019 sur une vidéo largement partagé sur
les réseaux sociaux on voit précisément
le déroulé des faits un policier mène
une charge contre un groupe de
manifestants et donne un coup de
matraque dans le dos d'une femme alors
en train de marcher tranquillement elle
tombe à terre et perd immédiatement
connaissance sur la vidéo les policiers
l'enjambent pour l'éviter avant que des
manifestants lui porte secours cette
femme c'est une amie noise de 41 ans qui
n'a pas pu travailler pendant plusieurs
jours après les faits aujourd'hui elle
réclame justice pour que ce type de
comportement policier ne soit plus
reproduit à l'avenir en ce qui concerne
les gilet jaune il célèbre cette semaine
le troisième anniversaire de larmes ou
mouvement depuis 2000 18 ans les
revendications sont les mêmes plus de
pouvoir d'achat baisse du prix du
carburant et de l'énergie est mise en
place du riq du référendum d'initiative
citoyenne entre autres il appelle à de
larges manifestations partout en france
ce samedi dans l'espoir de donner un
coup de boost à leur mouvement à cinq
mois de l'élection présidentielle il
espère en effet peser dans la campagne
électorale et que leurs revendications
soient reprises par les candidats à la
magistrature suprême